crooked Democrat prosecutors many of
them racists in Reverse they are
absolute racists in Reverse in Reverse
is being racist in reverse the same as
being the victim of racism maybe that's
what Trump means are trying to steal a
second presidential election are they
they did it in 2020 and we're not going
to let them do it again in 2024. Now
understand what Trump means is I tried
to steal a presidential election in
2024. in 2020 and I am going to try to
steal another one in 2024. that's really
what he means here make America great
again
there you go so Donald Trump putting out
these strange there's he's almost like
vlogging they're almost like video blogs
and none of it makes any sense but this
is increasingly the way that Trump
apparently wants to be communicating
with the followers that he has